What is the Justice Fund?
The Justice Fund
It is not part of the state budget.
It s like a wood fund.
about wood pool of money
to serve very specific people.
These are people who are victims of crime.
For example,
victims of violence
These are people leaving prisons.
so that they can return to society on different terms
and
These are goals related to crime prevention.
and only the justice fund is to serve these purposes
How to finance
Catholic organizations
Tackling the Causes of Crime
I can only tell you so much
that there are competition procedures yy in which
each organization has the right to request centers
on your soul of justice
These are transparent competitions.
Transparent there is no doubt about it.
I think
that these days
when when when
we can talk about some elaborate rules
They are also important
are also important
We are coming to such a moment.
Such organizations are also very
are highly recommended in situations
when you simply have to set an example in the world
The Justice Fund in Recent Years
relied on this
that After 1.
the final decision to grant
all means had
Minister of Justice and used it
yy even if the selection boards yy promoted
yy have selected the entity
to get funding
The Minister of Justice could say
e e yy from the 2nd page yy
yy measures
These were spent for purposes
Not related to the Justice Fund
Third,
there was a lack of transparency.
So we didn't know at all
yy very often who won the contest yy how many got
Money and on what basis
short ball watch us